all right after that wacky trumpet
interlude with darlene swaffer let's get
into the last component of this
dystopian rally over the weekend the
attendees the people who went to the
trump rally because remember without
followers the movement is nothing here
is a woman who started crying she
started crying because she misses trump
so much this country trump loves this
country i love my country
we need to straighten this country up i
have children and we need
we need you trump
our country is going to
yeah i agree with you i'm gonna give you
a hug man this is why this is why we do
this for people like you because we know
how important it is for we know we love
this country we know exactly
this is more sad than anything else i
mean you know crying because trump was
president makes more sense like crying
because it's it was such a terrible
a terrible episode in this country says
like that would make sense you know it
was horrible it was absolutely
humiliating globally
crying because you want the guy back so
bad that is just very very strange then
they interviewed another woman
who said she's planning to cry when
trump comes out on stage so what's your
anticipation for today i mean you've got
thousands of people here you've got mike
lindell behind us he's going to walk out
on that on that platform it's just going
to be exciting
it's i i will probably cry when i see
him and everybody else this is very
emotional
because we're finally people are finally
waking up to what happened in 2020
i agree it's very emotional same thing
it's a very emotional experience when he
walks around the stage it is i was in
washington d.c
and that was amazing on which day on
january 6th for the ellipse
that was millions what a great day that
was that was an amazing day
this is a cult leader guys this i it's
it's sounding more and more like the
cultists you read about when you read
about charles manson when you read about
the people's temple uh the same woman
was asked why she likes trump listen to
what she says it's the opposite of
what's true why do you love president
trump
well he's honest he's the biggest liar
in the history of american presidents
undeniable fact he's a christian he's
obviously not a christian he doesn't
know anything about the bible he didn't
go to church he concocted that to trick
people like this woman and it worked
that's why he did it because it worked
the proof is in the pudding this woman
believed it um anti-abortion he's not
anti-abortion he was in favor of choice
until he was 68 he decided to run and
said i gotta come up with some story
about why i'm against abortion and he
came up with i met a kid i liked and the
mom told me she once thought about an
abortion and from that day forward i was
a and that happened when he was 68.
they've fallen for all of it
and he calls it like it is he says what
all of us are thinking if we're all
thinking the things trump says we're
screwed we're really screwed then they
spoke to some guy who's running for
school board on an anti-critical race
theory platform
no crt right no crt
matter of fact plus one is two if you
have two x chromosomes you are a what
female yes come on people biology
one-on-one the funniest part is
this is not the crowd that knows about
biology you know that if
[Laughter]
i don't want to belabor that but if
you're trying to ask chromosomal or
genetic questions
the people waiting to go to the trump
rally i'm sorry guys are not exactly the
people that you ask um okay then
i can't do too too much of this but um
let's go to
a woman who also
i guess why she loves trump say about it
you love your trump absolutely number
one reason why you love president trump
is why he's gonna save america and he
loves us
he absolutely loves us you know what's
really funny and sad about that
one of the things we've learned is trump
doesn't love these people trump's
followers are the people he spent his
life trying to stay away from
and if they are useful to him voting
wise he'll pretend to like them
and if they're useful donor-wise he'll
pretend to like them but then he'll
abandon them he'll screw them he'll scam
them and you know what if he runs in 24
he'll pretend to like them again but
they've fallen for all of it last one
listen this one you can't even come up
with an introduction to this one donald
trump you know he's the modern day
muhammad ali you know yes sir yes
something like a b he's gonna hit harder
next time right here the only similarity
i can think of between trump and
muhammad ali is both figured out ways
not to go to vietnam albeit for very
different reasons muhammad ali because
he was an objector
and trump because
he was i guess scared and claimed to
have bone spurs so that that's that's
the only thing i can think of uh very
scary stuff these people vote which
means we have to vote
one of our sponsors is real paper our
forests on earth remove about a quarter
of the carbon that humans put into the
atmosphere and yet every day we're
cutting down tens of thousands of trees
to make single-use paper products real
paper is fighting back real paper makes
paper products that are truly
sustainable their paper towels and
toilet paper
are 100 plastic free made without any
virgin tree fibers meaning no new trees
are cut down but real paper is super
soft and durable you don't have to
sacrifice quality to help the planet
these are great products from a
usability standpoint i'm using real
paper at home you can do a one-time
purchase they also have easy
subscriptions all orders ship in 100
recyclable plastic free packaging
everybody needs paper towels and toilet
paper buy ones that you will feel good
about and they're giving my audience 30
off a subscription when you go to
realpaper.compacman
and use the code pacman the link is down
below